[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله شهد العراق
اشتباكات ضاريه بين قوات الامن ومسلحين في
عدد من
المناطق عنف متصاعد جاء على خلفيه ما تسبب
فيه اقتحام الجيش العراقي
لاعتصام الحويجه من سقوط العشرات بين قتلى
وجرحى نتوقف مع هذا الخبر ناقشه في
محورين وجهه المالك في التعامل مع ازمه
العراق في ضوء احداث
الحويجه مستقبل الازمه في بلاد رفيد من
خلال ردود الفعل على الاحداث
الجاريه على صوت الاقتتال في انحاء متعدده
من عراق بين القوات الحكوميه والمسلحين في
تصعيد خطير جاء على خلفيه ما نجم عن احداث
الحويجه من سقوط عدد كبير من القتلى
والجرحى احداث تباينت المواقف من مبرراتها
وسبل التعامل مع تداعياتها وسط مخاوف
متزايده من ان تعود بلاد الرافدين الى
دوامه العنف طائفي باشرس مما
كان الله
هل دفن حل المالكيه السياسي الهش لاحتواء
المظاهرات السنيه في العراق والمستمره منذ
اربعه اشهر تزمن تشييع قتل اقتحام الجيش
ساحه المعتصمين في قضاء الحويجه بكركوك مع
مواجهات بين مسلحين وقوات الامن في مناطق
متفرقه من البلاد دارت اعنف الاشتباكات في
سليمان بيك بمحافظه صلاح الدين القريبه من
كركوك اهي بدايه مرحله جديده في حراك
يفترض انه بدا مطالبه رئيس الوزراء نور
المالكي بجمله من الاصلاحات فال الاصوات
المناديه بتسليح المتظاهرين هي التي تفرض
نفسها على الاحداث وهي بالطبع اخطر ما
يهدد بلدا يبحث عن استقراره المفقود منذ
الغزو الامريكي قد تكون شعره معاويه قطعت
عندما اقتحم الجيش ساحه المعتصمين واشتبك
مع بعضهم وقتل عشرات منهم وخسر عددا من
جنوده تقول الروايه الرسميه ان الجيش تدخ
للقضاء على مسلحين وبانه عثر على كميه من
الاسلحه يرد المعارضون ان من في الساحه
متظاهرون سلميون ولكن السؤال من اين جاء
السلاح الذي قتل الجنود العراقيين يذهب
البعض الى اتهام المالك بتعمد اعتماد
الخيار الامني في الحويجه على اساس انها
الساحه الاضعف مقارنه بالرمادي وسمراء
والفلو ليرسل النظام وفقهم من الحويجه
البعيده من العاصمه رساله الى باقي المحتج
في المناطق القريبه من بغداد ليست
الجغرافيا هي السبب الوحيد بل ايضا
التركيبه السكانيه لكركوك التي تجعل من
وضعها الخاص ساحه تستغل في التجاذبات
السياسيه المعلنه وغير المعلنه ولا شك ان
بعض الاطراف السياسيه ستجد في احداث
الحويجه ورقه اخرى لتصفيه حساباتها مع
الملك وقد يصب بيان الزعيم التيار الصدري
في هذا الاتجاه فقد حمل الحكومه المسؤوليه
عن فتح باب جديد للعن في اللامشروع
والمفرط محذرا من عواقب غير مستحسن على
الاطلاق حتى في حال نجح المالك في اقناع
مسلحي الطريقه النقش بنديه في كركوك بوضع
السلاح جانبا فحضور فشله في المناطق
الاخرى المعاديه له كبيره المرجح هو ان
رئيس الوزراء العراقي نجح فقط في تعزيز
موقف خصومه السياسيين ودفع المتظاهرين الى
احتمال رفع سقف مطالبهم
بالسلاح اذا لمناقشه هذا الموضوع سينضم
الينا من ميدان الحق بسمراء ناجح عباس
الميزان وهو المتحدث باسم المعتصمين ومن
دبي عزه الشابندر عضو ائتلاف دوله القانون
طبعا
سنناقش وجهه نظر الطرفين حول ما جرى في
الحويجه وعن ابعاده والاسباب التي دعت
الحكومه والمالك تحديدا الى استعمال القوه
لفض والتدخل بقوه في ميدان او في ساحه
المعتصمين نبدا مع ناجح عباس الميزان
الناطق باسم المعتصمين من ميدان الحق في
سمراء ما هي الرساله التي وصلتكم ناجح
عباس الميزان من القوه التي تعاملت بها
السلطات العراقيه مع المعتصمين في
الحويجه رساله مو غريبه علينا اخي العزيز
هذا هو ديدن الحكومه وهذا هو الشان
المالكي وحكومته يتعاملون بالقوه ويقتلون
شعبهم في كل مكان حكومه منذ ان بدات ولحد
انجازاتها التي تعتز بها هي قتل الشعب
العراقي في كل مكان وخاصه السنه العرب لا
هم له ولا استراتيجيه له الا قتل السنه كل
ما يطلبونه منه وكلما يستخدمون اساليب
يعني اخر اساليب اللي استخدمناها هو ماده
38 من الدستور تعطي حق لنا في التظاهر
والاعتصام والمطالبه بحقوقنا بشكل سلمي
بدل ان يحقق مطالبنا وحقوقنا ان يعطينا
ايا
بعد 110 ايام 115 يوم استعمل الجيش الجيش
في ضرب المعتصمين العزل وبدم بارد يقتلون
في صباح في المساء وهم يصلون على السجادات
يقتلون 200 شخص بين قتيل وجريح والان
والان وصل العدد الى حدود 100 او فوق ال
يشهد سيد ناجح انت الان تصف الحكومه وتصف
المالكي وكانها مجموعه من العصابه لا هم
لها سوى قتل الناس
وقتل الس الاهالي او المواطنين بينما يرى
انصار الحكومه ان من واجب الحكومه وكما في
كل بقاع العالم على على عاتق الحكومات ان
تبسط سيطرتها و تسيطر على المناطق التي قد
تراها هي خارجه عن
القانون القانون خارجه عنا نحن معتصمون
بماده 38 بالدستور هذه ماده دستوريه وهناك
قوانين مشرعه تعطي للمواطن الحق يا اخي هي
ممارسه حضاريه جدا يعني الحمد لله والشكر
الممارسات التي قمنا بها والمطالب بحقوقنا
بسويسرا ما في يعني ما في اي شي ممارسه
اخذنا حالنا ورحنا رشنا الارض وال تحفنا
السماء ورفعنا لافتات ولا نستخدم سلاح
وغادرنا جميع ما هو يخالف القوانين
والدستور الى اين نذهب وفق الشريعه وفق
الدستور وفق القانون وطلبنا بكل
يا اخوان اعطونا حقوقنا لكن الذي حدث فعلا
يعني اذا يعني الوصف الذي وصفته وانت لا
تقتنع به فعلا هي مجموعه من المليشيات
وهذا الذي حدث ولكن باي باي قانون هل يحق
للجيش التدخل في في الشان الداخلي الجيش
العراقي وجميع جيوش العالم تدافع هو هي
اسمها وزاره الدفاع وليست وزاره
هذا الجيش مكانه الطبيعي على الحدود كان
حري بالجيش العراقي ان يذهب الى خان ال فط
خانقين لكي يدافع عن النفط الذي اخذته
ايران عنوه ولكي يدافع عن حقنا في المياه
في الانهر التي قطعتها علينا ايران وان
يدافع عن جميع الاراض التي ما ذهب الجيش
الا بالداخل هذا
ليس من مساحات عمل الجي هذه اعمال
الداخليه ان تلبي مط الشعب وليس قفله انا
مضطر ان اواصل معك في انتظار ان ان يكون
السيد عزه الشابندر الذي سيلتحق بنا من
دبي وهو عضو البرلمان العراقي اتلا دوله
القانون جاهزا للرد على كثير من النقاط
ولكن اريد ان اسال
ايضا يعني بوجهه النظر الطرف الاخر ان
هؤلاء المعتصمين طبعا ليسوا كلهم معتصمين
وقانونيين كما تقول وفقا لما ينص عليه
الدستور وانما كان بينهم في ساحه الاعتصام
مسلحون و والسلطه ضبطت كميه كبيره من
السلاح بل وسقط ايضا من بين القتلى عدد
كبير من قوات النظام هل تنكر بان هناك
مسلحين كانوا بين
المعتصمين سيد ناجح
عباس للاسف حتى الاتصال معنا ناجح عباس
انقطع الان سناخذ هذا الفاصل اي لعل وعسى
بعده ربما ضيوفنا قد يكون جاهزين ونعود
اليكم فبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدنا الكرام في
هذه الحلقه التي تناقش الاوضاع القائمه في
العراق على ضوء ما ترتب عن اقتحام القوات
العراقيه لاعتصام الحويجه ل لنرى ان كان
المالكي وحكومته قد يعتمدوا ايه سياسه
القوه لفض الاعتصامات والتعامل مع الحركه
الاحتجاجيه انضم الينا الان عزه الشابندر
عضو البرلمان العراقي من اتلاف دوله
القانون وكان معنا قبل قليل ناجح عباس
الميزان الناطق باسم المعتصمين في ميدان
الحق في مدينه سمراء سيد عزه شمندر مرحبا
بك سيد نجي حباس مزان قال قبل قليل بان
الحكومه لم تتعامل بالشكل الدستوري
المطلوب مع حركه قانونيه دستوريه يعني
حركه احتجاجيه جماعيه من من من اهالي
المنطقه وفق ما ينص عليه الدستور لكن
المالكي تعامل مع هؤلاء بالقوه لماذا راهن
الملكي على القوه لفضل
الاعتصام شكرا لك مرحبا السؤال السؤال ليس
دقيق المالكي لم يتعامل مع الاعتصامات
بالقوه لا هذا الاعتصام ولا غيره اربعه
اشهر او ما يفوق ذلك الاعتصامات قائمه
ومستمره ولا يوجد من يتعرض لهذه
الاعتصامات من قريب او من
بعيد الذي حصل في
الحويجه هناك مجرمون
ارهابيون اعتدوا على مواقع
حكوميه قوات امنيه في اكثر من موقع ولجوا
الى ساحه
الاعتصام ماذا ينبغي ان تفعل الحكومه
العراقيه تتركهم هل ان صاحه
باعتصام اصبحت سيف سايد للمجرمين هل هي
ملجا للمجرمين طولب الساده قاده الاعتصام
ووجهاء
الاعتصام بان افتحوا الطريق اما ان يسلموا
هؤلاء القتله وما استولوا عليه من اسلحه
او يسمحوا للجيش ان يدخل للتفتيش وبقيت
هذه
المفاوضات ما يفوق الاربعه ايام بلياليها
وقد تدخل العديد من عيون المنطقه وعشائرها
ولكن لم ينفع بعد ذلك قررت الحكومه ان
تدخل ساحه
الاعتصام بالطريقه المعمول بها دوليا
وقانونيا طبعا بعد الحديث المسهب لقائد
العمليات ولقا الجيش والشرطه بالسماعات
وبشكل مباشر وعن قرب ان انه احنا راح نيجي
يا اخوان نفتش فارجوكم تسمحوا لنا ولا
تطلقوا نار ولا راح نطلق نار وفعلا دخلوا
واللي دخلوا هو شرطه مكافحه الشغب الجيش
كان متاخر
عنها كثيرا وشرطه مكافحه الشغب ايضا
استعملت مكبرات الصوت وتحدثت مع
المعتصمين ولم تلقى جوابا الا السب
والشتيمه والاتهامات فاستعملت خراطيم
المياه استعملت قنابل مسيله للدموع لتفريق
هذه الدموع التي كانت اصلا مسلحه ولو
باسلحه بيضاء ولكن حينما استعملت القوات
الامنيه ادوات مكافحه الشغب بدا القنص من
اربع اتجاهات وسقط العديد من القتلى
والعديد من الجرحى من القوات الامنيه في
هذه اللحظه الا ينبغي على القوات الامنيه
ان تدافع عن وجود ها فنعم اطلقت النار
فعلا على
مصادر اطلاق النار ردهم وحصل ما حصل سيد
ناجح عباس الميزان سمعت هذه الروايه الان
من سيد عزه البندر الحكومه يعني قامت بكل
ما كان يفترض ان تقوم به قبل ان تتدخل
يعني حاولت قاله الاعتصام طلبت منهم تسليم
هؤلاء الذين وصفتهم بالمجرمين
والارهابيين وتسليمهم وتسليم سلاحهم لكنكم
رفضتم هل هكذا الامر كما وصفه السيد
شبندر توفى قلت ان نجيب محفوظ يعمل في
حكومه المالكي ويؤلف له الروايات هذا
الكلام عارا عن الصحه تماما يؤسفني ان
اقول هذا الذي حدث هناك مشاجره بين اثنين
واحد في الجيش ومن اقاربه من عشيره العبيد
اللي حدث
بيناتهم بدات الجيش بدا الجيش يستخدم طبعا
هي قبلها قبلها باسابيع الجيش يفتش ويتحرش
بالمعتصمين ويستعرض القوه امامهم ويستعمل
معهم اللغه الطائفيه والسب والشتم كلما
دخلوا وخرجوا هذا معروف للجميع ولكن الذي
حدث هذه المره هذا الرجل لن يدخل الى
الاعتصام الذي قتل اقاربه والقضيه عشائريه
بحته وليس الجيش علاقه بهذا الامر لا من
قريب ولا من بعيد ولكن هذا الامر استخدموه
لكي يدخلوا على المعتصمين ومعلوم للجميع
ان ساحات الاعتصام هي مجموعه من الناس
المسمين الذي يريد ان يستخدم السلاح لا
يدخل الى ساعات الاعتصام ماكان الاسلحه
والمقاومه وغير ذلك هو في الطرق السريعه
وغير اماكن والجيش ما الذي ياتي بمسلحي
يدخل هنا هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه ال
ط عندما دخل الجيش الاماكن الى هذه
الاماكن كان اليوم التقرير الطبي طلع كل
الضرب في القلب وفي الراس وبعد متر
واحد قتلوهم لم يحملوا السلاح اطلاقا وهذا
واضف الى ذلك كل عمليه من هذا النوع هناك
الات تصوير نتحدى الشابندر ووزير الدفاع
والمالكي ان يعرضوا لنا صور للاقتحام هذا
من ناحيه واتحداهم ان يعلنوا اسماء الذين
قتلوا من الجيش ومن هم اهلهم واين فواتح
هذه الامور وهذه التبريرات وهذه الروايات
المفركه من اجل قتل الناس بدافع طائفي فل
يغادروها افضل مما يقتلون الناس بالكذب
والدجل وتاليف الروايات اللي ما انزل الله
بها ابو السلطان يا اخي العزيز كما قلت لك
الجيش ليس مكان للجيش في الاعتصامات
الاعتصامات سلميه ومعروف 120 يوم الناس
معتصمين لم تصدر منهم اطلاقه واحده من اين
اتت هذه القناصين ولكن اعيد واقول فلياتوا
باسماء المقتولين ان كانوا صادقين وليوا
بالصور والكاميرات ان كانوا صادقين ايضا
ولكن طيب سيد عزيز الشندر اي كلمه
الشابندر يعني الان المالكي باعتماده
القوه في فض هؤلاء المعتصمين او في
التعامل مع هذه الحركه الاحتجاجيه يعني
الان وكانه دخل بالعراق او ادخل العراق
الى مرحله اخرى الان بعدما كان سقف بعدما
سالت الدماء بات سقف هؤلاء المعتصمين
والمحتاج جين مفتوحا وعاليا جدا ما هي
خيارات المالك الان بعدما دخل العراق في
مرحله بدنا نسمع فيها التهديد من كلا
الطرفين بالتعامل بالقوه وملامح التصعيد
الامني الخطير الذي يه تهدد البلاد بدات
واضحه الان في اماكن
عده انت والله من منيح تتكلم نيابه عن
ساحات الاعتصام بشكل متقن يعني بارك الله
فيك انت مو على الحياد ابدا في حديثك هذا
بس انا تعودت على هذه الات اتهامات وتحصنت
يعني منها س العزيزه الشابندر لك ان تقول
ما شئت اريد منك جوابا عن سؤالي من فضلك
تحملت اعطيك جواب الاخ العراقي الاخ
العراقي الذي تحدى من حقه ان يتحدى لكن
انت لك ان تقول يعني خليني اتكلم يا اخي
خليني اتكلم تفضل يا اخي بدون رفع
صوتك اقول الاخ العراقي من حقه ان يتحدى
لعل عذره في جهله في المعلومات او فيما
وقع هو راد صور راح نعطيه افلام هو راد
وثائق عرضنا على التلفزيون وسنعرض كل
الوثائق التي عثر عليها في مقر
الاعتصام كل بيانات
النقشبنديه
ومسلاتهم مع بعض كلها
قدمت الى هيئه تقصي الحقائق وقدمت الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي وقدمت الى كوبلر مبعوثه
المنظمه الدوليه للامم المتحده احنا نقبل
هذا التحدي ولكن اتمنى ان اسمع من اخي
المعتصم اذا عرضنا عل كل هذه الوثائق التي
يريد واسماء الذين استشهدوا ايضا من قوات
الجيش
وطه ماذا سيحصل بعد
ذلك نقبل هذا التحدي بكل رحابه صدر ومحبه
واقول له ولك ان ساحه الاعتصام مفتوحه
ولهم ان يعتصموا
سلميا ولهم ان يرفعوا ما يشاؤون من
الشعارات الا الشعارات الطائفيه فهي
ممنوعه
دستوريا لهم ان يشتموا المالكي يشتموا
الحكومه ويقولوا ظلم واستبداد وتهميش
واقصاء ولكن لا تثير النعرات الطائفيه هذا
منحى خطير ونحن نعرف من يقول هذا التوجه
ونعرف من يريد ان يجعل العراق جزء من اتون
المنطقه الطائفيه احن نقبل هذا التحدي
وبامكان الجزيره ان تستلم غدا او بعد غد
كل الافلام التي تريد وتعرض اذا كانت
الجزيره محايده تعرض على شاشاتها الان
رئيس هيئه تقص الحقائق السيد الدكتور صالح
المطلق نائب رئيس الوزراء كوبلر الاتحاد
الاوروبي السفير الاسباني هو يمثل الاتحاد
الاوروبي في العراق بامكانكم ان تاخذوا كل
هذه الوثائق وعندنا من ال 26
ممن قتلوا او سقطوا من المعتصمين سته من
قاده الطريقه النقشبنديه
العسكريين من القاد العسكريين
والميداني وعندنا ايضا ما لا يبلغ الشك او
الريب اليه عدد عدد وانواع السلاح التي
عثر عليها في ساحه الاعتصار ط ناجح عباس
سمعت ما يقول شابندر هناك وثائق وهناك
تسجيلات وهناك غير ذلك من الاسماء الذين
من العناصر التي قتلت وتعرض على جهات سواء
في الداخل او في الخارج وهناك دعوات الى
التحقيق اليس من المناسب لكم ان تفسحوا
المجال لهذه لهذه التحقيقات ان يعني ان
يعني تظهر الحقائق لوقوف على حقيقه ما جرى
قبل فوات الاوان وقبل دفع العراق الى يعني
سيناريوهات لا تحمد عقباها سيد
ناجح والله يا اخي انا صدد الرد عليه وانا
اعلم انهم لا توجد وكل الوثائق الذي
سيعرضون والذي عرضوها وضعوا الاسلحه 40
قطعه سلاح كلاش الكوف وهذا متوفر وهذا
سلاح الجيش العراقي وضعوها وصوروا هم
وضعوها هم صوروها والباقي كلها اموات واذا
كان هناك وثائق فكلها وثائق موجوده عندهم
متى ما شاء عرضها واذا يريد ان يعطي اسماء
لمقتول فاعلم ان هؤلاء الاسماء كما قدم
اسماء المقتولين في الفلوجه كانوا مقتولين
في في مكان اخر وقد صور نفسه الشعب الدر
بان المقتولين قتلوهم اهل الفلوجه وكل
القنوات صورت كيف قتل من قبلهم الفلوجه
وكيف قتلوا من قبلهم اهل الموصل هذه ليس
بالحادثه الجديده لكن انا اريد ان اقول
هذا الكلام لن ينفع الان نحن الان ذهبنا
الى حاق المق وعلى التحالف الوطني وعلى
المرجعيه اليوم المالكي فقد شرعيته كقائد
للعراق اليوم احنا ذهبنا الى مذهب اخر
وليت تتع المالكي بقتل بقتل المعتصمين و
اليوم من عائله حده يقتل اربعه ماذا يقول
في اسلام اليوم من امس الى اليوم الطاقه
تقصف وال المدعيه تقصف الدبابات تقصف هذول
هم نقش بيه وهم عندهم مثيق وهم قتل قتلوا
الجيش شو سميها الان المعركه طائرات
والمعركه دبابات في اسلمان بيت لكن الذي
اريد ان اقول قبل ان نذهب الى المناكفات
والى الكذب الصريح والوا واضح نقول اننا
سنحرق المطالب ال 14 والتسعه ولا نريد الا
مطلب واحد وهو رحيل المالكي على المرجعيه
والتحالف الوطني ان يقيل المالكي او
يستقيل المالكي لان لا يصلح لقياده العراق
وعلينا ونحن الذي سنختار هذه المره سنختار
من منهم من التحالف الوطني من نقتنع به ان
يكون صالحا لقياده العراق والا لن نسمح
مره ثانيه ان ياتي بدل المالكي على الاديب
او حضرته ويقتلنا يعتقنا وينتهك الحرمات
ويقتل بدم بارد لن نقبل هذه المره هناك من
الاخيار في التحالف الوطني من الكثير منهم
من من العوائل الكبار سنختار والا لن نرجع
الى المطالب ولو حققها من بعد يوم الجمعه
ولو حققها وزاد عليها 14 و14 و1 لن نقبل
الان الان العشائر كلها انتفضت ومع الاسف
الشديد نحن اسفون جدا انه اوصلوا القضيه
انه العشائر تسلحت وخرجت للدفاع عن دماء
وعن اعراضها وعن حرياتها لان هذه الحكومه
واذهب الى الحويز واذهب الى سليمان بي
واذهب الى جميع والى
الانبار ان العشا ماذا سيقولون ان
العبيد والجبور والتوام والكا هل يقولون
هؤلاء ارهابيون ونشون وغير ذلك
ودامون انته الوقت سجح عباس نجح عباس
الميزان انتهى الوقت نجح عباس الميزان نطق
باسم المعتصمين في ميدان الحق في مدينه سم
بالعراق شكرا لك ونشكر ضيفنا من دبي عزه
الشاب بندر عضو البرلمان العراقي على
اتلاف دوله القانون بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
في قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد شكرا
لكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]
وبركاته
ه